ah
bienvenidos a reporteros el magazine de
los grandes reportajes de la redacción
de france 24 soy herminia fernández
hoy continuamos con el cuarto episodio
de nuestra serie de fronteras en laos el
único país del sudeste asiático sin
costa se espera que una línea de tren de
alta velocidad sea la promesa de una
apertura y de un nuevo auge económico el
enlace ferroviario de 420 kilómetros
tarda sólo tres horas en conectar la
capital de laos vendían con china en la
frontera entre china y laos se está
construyendo la zona económica especial
de bote en un proyecto de 10 mil
millones de dólares en la década de 2000
voten se convirtió en una ciudad casi no
muy popular entre los chinos pero en
2021 beijing impuso el cierre de todos
los establecimientos de juego sumiendo
al pueblo en un letargo ahora ha
renacido con esta zona económica
especial en la actualidad establecer un
negocio voten es relativamente sencillo
los trámites administrativos se pueden
realizar en 15 días muchos productos
están exentos de impuestos y el sistema
fiscal es ventajoso
debido a estos beneficios en los últimos
tres años un centenar de empresas se ha
instalado en esta floreciente ciudad
adri verger y dará pata mont informan
con severin bardón y olivier marceau
[Música]
diciembre de 2021 en la flamante
estación de tren de vientiane laos
inaugura su primera gran línea de tren
[Música]
este día es muy importante en la
historia de laos este nuevo y moderno
medio de transporte hará que nuestro
país se desarrolle aún más es un sueño
hecho realidad jim el presidente de la
os habla con su homólogo chino a través
de una pantalla debido a la pandemia del
cob it
[Música]
y en esta ocasión me gustaría expresar
mi gratitud al presidente de sikkim
pinging y al gobierno chino por su
invaluable ayuda
la línea de alta velocidad de 420 km fue
construida y financiada en un 70% por
china como parte de las nuevas rutas de
la seda'
los pasajeros del viaje inaugural del
ferrocarril laos china están invitados a
subir a bordo el tren está a punto de
salir desde vientián el tren tarda sólo
tres horas en llegar a la frontera desde
allí el ferrocarril se conecta con la
red china para laos el único país sin
salida al mar del sudeste asiático es la
promesa de una apertura y un nuevo auge
económico
[Música]
y hay un lugar donde esta promesa ya
tiene sabor a realidad pot en la ciudad
fronteriza del lado la océano
imagine he venido a recoger un coche de
china por ahora está en un almacén a
quien voten lo revisaré y lo traeré a
vientián voten ha crecido mucho y a las
empresas de logística les está yendo muy
bien aquí
con sólo distintos
[Música]
en la frontera entre china y laos se
está construyendo la zona económica
especial de boten
este proyecto de 10.000 millones de
dólares desarrollado íntegramente por
una empresa china en suelo laosiano
comenzó en 2016
[Música]
en 2035 la nueva ciudad debería tener
300.000 habitantes
[Música]
si maestra estaba es muy cómodo de
llevar perfecto para el año nuevo la o
sea no
no es de vientiane la capital de laos se
trasladó a boten con sus hijos para
estar más cerca de su marido chino y
aprovechar las oportunidades de negocio
de la ciudad fronteriza en este momento
hay mucho interés por este producto
desde hace tres años dirige este pequeño
bazar de barrio que ofrece productos de
bajo costo
estos zapatos vienen de china estos
vienen de vietnam la mayoría de los
zapatos provienen de estos dos países
[Música]
vietnam a una medida tonella
ropa cosméticos objetos cotidianos de
poco valor en la tienda de noy la
mayoría de los productos son importados
y los precios se dan más a menudo en
yuanes chinos que en kits laosianos una
forma de adaptarse a la clientela local
la mayoría de la gente que vive en bote
no es de aquí son de otras provincias y
de china vinieron a instalarse justo
después de la construcción de la ciudad
han alquilado casas y locales
comerciales
además de clinton el embargo de
sangre
van mindfulness wawel bottle
voten tiene una historia única en la
década de 2000 este pequeño y adormecido
pueblo situado en el límite de laos se
convirtió en una ciudad casi no muy
popular entre los chinos pero en 2011 el
gobierno de beijing impuso el cierre de
todos los establecimientos de juego y
boten volvió a caer en el letargo hasta
su renacimiento como zona económica
especial
aquí en 2015-2016 no había nada solo
campos y una pequeña plaza ahora hay
edificios por todas partes
[Música]
siento algo cansado
la ciudad cuenta ahora con dos mil
habitantes el 80 por ciento de los
cuales son chinos steven show es un
pionero que se trasladó a voten en una
etapa temprana ya visto su espectacular
desarrollo a lo largo de los años en la
fábrica que abrió aquí hace siete años
casi la mitad de los empleados son
chinos
y este aún no lo has rellenado verdad
no tienes que esperar otros 20 minutos
para este empresario chino a la elección
de voten fue el resultado de un cálculo
bien meditado y una apuesta de futuro
en 2005 construir una fábrica de aromas
de tabaco nos invade
y luego en 2015 china lanzó las rutas de
la seda'
y pensé que la hoz podría ser una gran
oportunidad para mí así que trasladé mi
fábrica de áfrica house
elegí hotel porque la mayoría de mis
clientes están en china y voten es una
zona económica especial de la frontera
entre laos y china
además existe un programa de ayuda al
desarrollo industrial
en bot en crear una empresa es fácil los
trámites administrativos se realizan en
15 días muchos productos están exentos
de impuestos y el sistema fiscal es
favorable en tres años un centenar de
empresas se han instalado en esta ciudad
aún en construcción
debido al cob y el desarrollo de boten
se han ralentizado pero estoy convencido
de que en cuanto la pandemia termine
potentísimo volverá a desarrollarse muy
rápidamente habrá un boom económico a
esta ciudad
las estrictas políticas de contención
tanto por parte de la osx como de china
han afectado mucho a bot en la mayoría
de los chinos de la ciudad regresaron a
su tierra natal antes del cierre de la
frontera
gracias one está súper para llevar la
servicio seremos sólo nosotros amarillas
y nunca pensó en dejar voten incluso
frenada por la pandemia la ciudad de
ofrece oportunidades que no encontraría
en ningún otro lugar de laos
hago algunas entregas lo hacemos todos
los días más o menos no es mucho pero es
algo debido a la situación económica
actual ayer entregamos un poco de
cerveza sólo unas pocas cajas
en borneo
[Música]
solo lleva tres años aquí pero la joven
ya ha abierto un segundo negocio de
venta y reparto de bebidas a granel
pero es demasiado pesado sólo se toma
uno así ahora emplea a cinco personas y
no tiene intención de detenerse ahí
si las fronteras se reabren tendré más
trabajo
también podréis repartir y vender ropa
tendré tanto trabajo que no podría
hacerlo todo yo sola
y necesitaré contratar
hay que cortarlo
aunque las dos comunidades no se mezclan
mucho los chinos y los laosianos de
boten comparten el mismo optimismo solo
difieran de los sueños y los medios
con la jefe ha pasado mucho tiempo
cómo están bienvenidos siente siento
todo en un flamante salón de té steven
show conoce a un compatriota esta fue
una oportunidad para que los dos hombres
hablarán de negocios y perspectivas de
futuro
[Música]
cómo van los negocios este año
empezamos la producción anteayer estará
lista el mes que viene los pedidos
fueron un poco más altos el año pasado
pero este año hay una clara influencia
del cobi
si uno tiene un plan de negocio a largo
plazo el cobit no es tan malo de hecho
si tiene objetivos a largo plazo esto es
realmente algo bueno
elimina las empresas menos competitivas
por ejemplo comprar este hotel si
estuviéramos en tiempos normales cuanto
me había costado
si es cierto a pesar del cob it o tal
vez debido a ello el señor sounds acaba
de comprar un hotel y varios edificios
más tiene previsto abrir una escuela
internacional trilingüe aprovechando la
situación geográfica de voten
en general es usted optimista sobre el
futuro de botella
en el marco de la ruta de la cena china
ha invertido cientos de miles de
millones en el sudeste asiático y
especialmente en laos con el ferrocarril
la autopista en el futuro las
inversiones de china en el sudeste
asiático se centrarán inevitablemente en
laos
en laos y en otros lugares muchas voces
se alzan para denunciar la dependencia
del país de china el dominio del reino
medio sobre su pequeño vecino
lejos de estas consideraciones políticas
los pioneros de voten como no y su
hermana que acaba de unirse a ella solo
esperan construir un futuro mejor
lo hace
[Música]
mi sueño en bogotá es comprar un auto y
un terreno
no tardará mucho ya lo verán cuando
llegué aquí no tenía nada pero ahora
tengo un auto una casa un terreno y
puedo mantener a mis hijos sólo se
necesita un poco de tiempo y paciencia
cuando vivíamos en vientián tampoco
teníamos nada y cuando vi el éxito que
tenían aquí decidí venir también crees
que lo haré también como tú claro que sí
gracias al tren ya las nuevas carreteras
abiertas recientemente entre china y
laos voten se ha convertido en un centro
de comunicaciones cuando la frontera se
convierte en un vínculo a veces también
se convierte en una tierra de
oportunidades
hasta aquí reporteros de la semana
recuerda que para sintonizar esta y las
emisiones anteriores puede visitar
nuestro sitio web france24 puntocom
hasta la próxima
[Música]